on va passer à l'invité du soir on va
revenir sur l'affaire pierre palmad qui
connaît un gros rebondissement quasiment
9 mois après le grave accident causé par
l'humoriste Pierre palmad a été
interrogé longuement par le la juge
d'instruction en charge de l'enquête et
on a appris aujourd'hui dans la presse
le contenu de l'interrogatoire qui vous
allez voir est assez incroyable on va
revenir donc sur les 10 les 10
confessions de Pierre Palmade à la juge
petit récap et Michel Marie est avec
nous juste après c'est
parti en février dernier Pierre palmat
provoquit un grave accident de la route
alors qu'il conduisait sous l'emprise de
stupéfiant aujourd'hui il est mis en
examen pour homicide involontaires et
blessures involontaires peu de temps
après le comédien qui avait été mis en
examen et placé dans un centre
d'adidictologie avait suscité la
polémique après avoir été aperçu en
boîte de nuit il est il est venu dans la
boîte ouais il est venu dans la boîte
convoqué par le tribunal judiciaire de
Melin en septembre dernier l'homme est
revenu pendant 3h sur ce jour dramatique
auprès d'un juge d'instruction où une
femme enceinte a notamment perdu son
bébé j'ai bousillé la vie d'une famille
alors qu'a-t-il dit l'accident ses
addictions sa rechute Michel Marie
revient sur l'incroyable récit de
l'audition de Pierre palmad face au
juges ce soir dans
TPMP merci Michel Marie d'être avec nous
on va revenir donc sur les 10
confessions de Pierre Palmade à la juge
Pierre Palmade était accompagné de son
avocate maître Cédric lassek et sa
collaboratrice étit visiblement abattu
dans une volonté de de se repentir il
craint très fort le procès qui aura lieu
dans quelques mois il a une diction qui
n'est pas très fluide pierre palmad
notamment à cause de son traitement et
des séquelles de son opération récente
de la carotite qui permet d'éviter la
récid d'AVC euh on va revenir donc sur
les les les 10 confessions même si
l'homicide en volontaire ne sera pas
retenu cont tenu du résultat des des des
analyses déjà sur le contexte avant
l'accident il reconnaît euh donc quelque
chose qui est important ah il reconnaî
qu'il conduisait sous l'emprise de
l'alcool et des
stupéfiants que le l'origine de
l'accident ce n'est pas comme on le
croyait à un moment donné d'avoir lu un
SMS à l'examen de sa téléphonie on
s'appelle aperçoit que le dernier appel
dernier SMS remonte à 45 minutes avant
l'accident donc il a joué Fran jeu avec
la juge instruction lors de cette très
longue audition qui a duré 3h c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'audition sur le fond qui
sera la dernière audition avant avant
son procès et elle a balayé absolument
tous les éléments du
dossier pendant cette audition de 3 He
alors il a dit les de jours précédents
pratiquement tout le temps j'ai consommé
en injection intraveineuse de la 3 MMC
Gill c'est ça c'est de la drogue c'est
drogue de synthèse c'est ce qu'il
prenait c'est ce qu'on prend pour le ce
qu'on appelle le Kems c'est-à-dire le le
sexe avec de la chimie avec ces droguesl
et qu'il matinait avec de la cocaïne
parce que ce médicament selon lui a
tendance à endormir et il prenait de la
cocaïne pour se rebooster alors de temps
en temps comme il a tendance à endormir
comme vous avez dit je prenais de la
cocaïne pour me réveiller c'est ce qu'a
dit Pierre Palm de J c'est la première
confession donc de Pierre Palmade sur
cette affaire et on savait qu'il s'était
piqué h fois entre le est l'accident ça
il l'avait on avait eu cet élément
incroyable donc il était et c'est
pendant 3 jours 3 jours et 3 nuits alors
deuxème confession sur l'accident il dit
avoir un trou de noir et se rappeler
seulement qu'il avait fait la fête avec
ses partenaires sexuels euphorisés dans
la voiture he c'est ça ouou il a aucun
souvenir de l'accident il dit il se
souvient d'être monté dans son
véhicule d'avoir pris le volant pour
aller faire des courses et il reprend le
le sens de la de l'existence il est sur
son lit d'hôpital entre les deux c'est
le trou noir alors il dit qu'il se
sentait apte à conduire pour all acheter
de la nourriture qui ne se souvient pas
de s'être disputé avec l'un des
passagers qui maintient avoir insisté
pour prendre le volant il a dit et je
cite malheureusement je suis toujours
victime de mon amnésie totale Gill c'est
c'est deuxème point sur ce deuxème point
ou c'est incroyable parce que en plus il
attendait une livraison de cocaïne de
Paris donc donc c'est-à-dire que la juge
lui a demandé d'ailleurs mais donc vous
vous conduisiez vite vous étiez pressé
parce que vous deviez être de retours
chez vous à son domicile pour que la
cocaïne arrive et qu'il soit là et là il
a répondu non et on sait depuis les
expertises Cyril que la voiture n'est
absolument pas en cause la route n'est
pas en cause la météo n'est pas en cause
donc voilà c'est lui qui est en cause le
SMS qui aurait pu le perturber et créer
l'accident n en réalité pas existé
puisque le dernier message reçu par
Pierre Palmade a eu lieu 45 minutes
avant l'accident c'est ce qu'on apprend
aussi he voilà donc cette thèse du SMS
qui aurait pu le perturber main SMS
est alors sur les causes de l'accident
puisque il explique du coup que c'est la
fatigue je suppose un épuisement de
fatigue totale subodor Pierre Palmade un
un déport comme ça je suppose que je
suis tombé de fatigue après 3 jours de
consommation de drogue sans dormir et
comme vous avveit dit il n'y avoir été
pressé par une livraison de drogue on
avait 30 minutes pour faire les courses
je devais me dépêcher mais ça ne m'a pas
fait conduire plus rapidement on aurait
eu le temps de les faire voilà donc ça
c'est c'est le deuxième point donc les
confidences de pierre palmat sur
accident il y a 10 points sur lesquels
on va revenir
euh sa culpabilité face aux blessures de
la famille euh Michel concernant
l'accident du 10 février dernier qui on
le rappelle a blessé grièvement trois
personnes dont un enfant et une mère
enceinte de 6 mois qui a perdu son bébé
on a souvent dit que Pierre Palm n'était
pas très ému par le sort de cette
famille qui a été très amimée par
l'accident mais face à la juge et Pierre
Palmade il semblait être bien différent
et rongé par le sentiment de culpabilité
il a dit euh il semble qu'il est comment
à prendre conscience de la gravité des
faits la gravité de cet accident
il il est il est il se présente comme un
homme brisé par ce qu'il a fait il a
beaucoup de de compassion pour les
victimes il dit que qui vit avec cette
histoire que ça quand il s'endort le
soir il y pense quand il se réveille le
matin quand il se lève le matin il y
pense également il a l'air d'être
sincère dans ses dans ses regrets mais
j'étais pas dans le bureau du juge au
moment où il il dit je suis horrifié de
savoir que je suis la cause de tout ça
quand j'ai su petit à petit les gravités
je suis d'abord pour le conducteur j'ai
vu toute l'ampleur des dégâts chez la
femme enceinte notamment sa peur de ne
plus pouvoir avoir d'enfant ça m'a
laminé c'est monstrueux j'ai bousillé la
vie d'une famille je m'endors et je me
lève avec ça sincèrement g parce que la
juge énumère petit à petit très
précisément toutes les blessures et ces
blessures qui sont encore récurrentes
des trois personnes donc elle elle lui
dit le conducteur multiopéré infirmité
permanente de la main gauche et il va
devoir encore être opéré le jeune
traumatisme crânien il va à l'école mais
il a encore des troubles et cette femme
donc qui était enceinte qui est très
fragile la juge évoque une dépression
profonde donc il prend conscience de
tout ça à ce moment-là voilà alors il
dit on a parlé on en a parlé l'expertise
médicale a confirmé que l'enfant qui
était porté par la passagère était mort
on en a parlé ici avant l'accouchement
ce qui écarte les poursuites pour
homicide involontaire he c'est ça qui
était un c'est ça qui est fou mine de
rien mais bon c'est c'est c'est la loi
et Pierre palmat se sont quand même
coupable de la mort d'un enfant je suis
responsable de la mort d'un enfant mon
accident a tué ce bébé dans son ventre
qu'il soit mort avant ou après
l'accouchement le résultat est même
c'est de ma faute il est plus
raisonnable que la justice c'est fort
c'est oui alors même que le cadre
juridique sera sans doute abandonné
domicide lui-même évoque la mort d'un
enfant il sera pas sans doute abandonné
il sera abandonné il sera abandonné
voilà il sera abandonné et il évoque
lui-même la mort d'un enfant oui avec
beaucoup d'élégance je
trouve lui en fait la subtilité c'est
légal ne ne l'intéresse pas il dit voilà
je suis responsable de la mort de cet
enfant que la justice tergiverse sur il
a respiré il a pas respiré j'ai tué cet
enfant voilà ce qu'
dit 4è point sa dépendance aux drogues
il a évoqué sa dépendance au drogue dur
et l'obligation de se soigner je me
rends compte que la thérapie est
nécessaire parce que j'étais tombé très
profond dans la drogue dans la tox
toxicomanie lourde c'est le 4 point al
il aurait du mal à ne pas reconnaître sa
consommation de de drogue euh mais
euh il l'a devant le juge d'instruction
parfaitement reconnu de même qu'il a
reconnu qu'il avait malgré le contrôle
judiciaire qui lui imposait de ne plus
pas d'être comment dirais-je soigné pour
pour son addiction il a replongé une
fois alors si je suis dans un contexte
particulier favorable à la consommation
cela peut être très dur de résister
l'idée de ne pas me mettre dans de
telles situations on peut avoir un
craving par exemple regarder un film qui
parle de drogue il faut trouver une
stratégie appeler un ami appeler son
parrain des narcotiques Anonymes changer
de film écrire c'est la bête noire du
dépendant Gill donc le craving c'est
l'impulsion de consommer donc lui ce
qu'il dit c'est qu'un jour il était mal
il arrive il rentre dans un café et puis
là quelqu'un lui propose ensuite d'aller
dans une discothèque gay il y va on lui
met du cette fameuse saloperie de trois
MMC là dans le dans la main et puis il
en prend et là il se dit ce n'est plus
possible je plonge et c'est là où il
demande à être de lui-même de nouveau
hospitalisé oui Michel il explique qu'il
est pas rentré dans ce bargay et ensuite
dans sa discothèque à des seins de
prendre de la drogue on va on va revenir
là-dessus on raconte tous ce qu' il dit
ça pierre palvan on Racon tous ce qu'on
a sur le cœur on est tenu au secret je
prends le risque de bénéficier d'une
aide de ce groupe qui respecte
l'anonymat puisqu'il raconte les
thérapies de groupe qu'il a fait ça
m'appte ce sont des dépendants qui me
comprennent il y a des abstinents depuis
20 ans ça donne de l'espoir mon rêve est
de vivre une vie sans drogue le 5è point
sur lequel Pierre palmad est revenu puis
qu'il y a 10 points lors de de de son sa
comparition face au juges sur les
réseaux sociaux vous le rappelez
plusieurs vidéos de Pierre palmad on
fait le boss cet été on a pu le voir à
l'ultra club la plus grande discothèque
gay friendendly de Bordeaux là où il est
depuis qu'il a quitté la région
parisienne il sera arrivé dans la
discothèque vers 3h du matin il reste il
serait resté 2h il est revenu sur cet
épisode face à la juge et à vous avoir
rechuté
oui c'est que commenç à
expliquer Gill euh un soir en sortant de
son narcotique association c'esturs le
comme pour les Alcooliques Anonymes
c'est les narcotiques Anonymes euh il
passe devant un barget il y a un gars
qui lui fait un sourire qui lui dit de
enfin qui le reconnaît qui lui fait
signe d'entrée et il est tellement seul
depuis cet accident tellement sans doute
perdu dans dans dans sa solitude que il
est content qu'on lui fasse un sourire
qu'il est content qu'on lui offre un
verre il rentre dans ce dans ce bar et
puis de fil en aiguille il se retrouve
dans une discothèque et c'est là
qu'effectivement il y a un type qui lui
met un un peu de 3 mm dans la dans la
poche et qu'il va consommer mais il le
reconnaît chez le chez la juge
instruction et il fera d'ailleurs le
nécessaire ensuite pour voir des
médecins et euh suivre une une cure
desintoxications il dit j'étais il a dit
à la jus j'étais seul à Bordeaux j'étais
sous le feu de tous les regards dans la
rue des invectifs par les passant en
rentrant des des narcotiques Anonymes je
suis passé devant un barrier comme vous
l'avez dit j'ai voulu trouver du
réconfort des sourires je suis entré les
gens étaient gentils avec moi je ne
pensais qu'à me changer les idées je me
suis laissé entraîner dans une
discothèque gay voilà Gill donc et là il
se rend bien compte face à la juge que
la juge va lui dire écoutez alors
justement on va parler de la juge pas
convaincu la N pas 6 il lui dit c'était
tout sauf de la désinvolture alors
justement le 6e point c'est la juge qui
n'a pas été convaincu cette chute n'a
pas du tout plus à la juge qui lui
aurait lancé votre comportement
interroge monsieur palmat sur votre
prise de conscience réelle de la gravité
des faits pour lesquels vous êtes mis en
examen et Pierre palmat ce serait
défendu c'est tout le cœur de la maladie
et de la dépendance je peux être rongé 1
heure avant par l'accident et est blessé
tant que je ne suis pas à 2 cm de la
gueule du loup je ne vois pas le danger
c'est tout sauf de la désinvolture je
comprends que cela soit perçu comme
scandaleux cela s'est fait pas à pas il
y a un Barguet quelqu'un me sourit deux
verres une boîte de nuit quelqu'un
s'assoit à côté de moi et met un paquet
dans la poche du pantalon et voilà c'est
plus fort que moi tout en assurant que
prendre de la drogue n'était pas son
objectif en se rendant dans cette boî de
nuit il redit j'en suis désolé je n'ai
pensé qu'à avoir quelques sourirees je
ne suis pas allé chercher la drogue je
n'avais rien derrière la tête j'ai
vraiment cru que c'était un réconfort je
n'avais pas pris la mesure de la proie
que j'étais de la médiatisation que
j'avais donc c'est ça voà oui là là il
joue la carte de la sincérité la plus
totale il il sait qu'il a fauté et il le
reconnaît euh alors c'est aussi une
stratégie avec son estce qu'il est
sincère ou pas on en sait rien exement
il joue la carte il joue la carte en
tout cas ce qu'il dit le 7è point de
l'affire Palmade puisque c'est fou que
tout soit sorti un incroyable récit de
l'audition de Pierre Palmade qu'on vous
raconte ce soir c'est que cette affaire
vous l'avez suivi avec nous depuis des
semaines et des semaines euh il dit je
veux être amoureux sans drogue être en
bonne santé ne plus fréquenter les gens
qui se droguent ça m'a gâché 30 ans de
ma vie je commence à sentir les
bienfaits de l'abstinence une santé
constante une forme constante et un
moral constant pour moi c'est une
nouveauté je vais pouvoir ressentir la
vie les émotions à moi de savoir les
encaisser donc l'état d'esprit de Pierre
Palm aujourd'hui Gill rédemption voilà
acte de contrition total j'ai fauté je
suis responsable de tout c'est moi je
crains le procès mais je serai jugé mais
ça va mieux je suis en dans une une
forme d'abstinence je vais essayer de
m'en sortir et je vous promets madame la
juge que je peux le faire voilà est-ce
qu'il l'a convaincu on ne sait pas mais
c'est ce qu'il a voulu faire passer
comme
message Michel donc là il essaie devant
la juge bien sûr de de dire qu' va c'est
normal oui il va pas dire
de toute façon je continuerai à me
droguer après avant et après le procès
donc évidemment devant la juge il tient
ses propos moi j'ai envie
de de dire que il a l'air sincère dans
dans dans ce qui raconte il reste
fragile l'épisode de cette boîte de nuit
le le
démontre il a suffit de de quelques
heures dans une boîte de nuit pour qu'il
replonge justement on va revenir sur les
trois derniers points parce qu'il dit il
rest réfute le fait que ces problèmes de
drogue soient liés à son homosexualité
ça c'est c'est bizarre d'avoir parlé ça
parce que je ne crois plus comme je le
clamis avoir des problèmes liés à mon
homosexualité je n'ai plus de raison de
fuir cette homosexualité là il n'y a
plus de honte par dit qu'en fait il
était tombé dans la drogue par qu'il a
20 ans très jeune parce qu'il n'assumait
pas voilà exaement et que là maintenant
qu'il l'assume entre guillemets il peut
devenir étranger à la drogue il peut
balayer la drogue c'est en tout cas ce
qu'il dit et ce qu'il pense
ça lui permettait aussi de chasser sa
timidité c'est ce qu'il explique c'est
foutu Pierre Palmade a également évoqué
son métier l'humoriste est conscient
qu'il ne remettra pas un pied sur scène
de siôt je n'aime qu'une chose dans la
vie c'est ma vie d'artiste écrire et
jouer des comédies et aujourd'hui je ne
suis pas sûr de pouvoir recommencer ce
métier je me pose des questions sur
l'avenir et l'préhension terrifiante du
procès qui m'attend alors oui oui
euh il est voilà donc là aujourd'hui il
dit qu'il va pas revenir terrifié par le
procès mais il sait qu'il y a cette
étape à franchir absolument et que donc
euh il ne peut pas évoquer devant la
juge l'idée de reprendre de remonter sur
scène parce que là elle va le prendre
très mal il se doute aussi
potentiellement qu'une audition comme ça
va fuiter imaginez qu'ils disent ensuite
je vais remonter sur scène redevenir
artiste ça va lui nuire donc là il dit
je ne suis plus du tout voilà c'est
c'est c'est exactement Géraldine ça l
profile c'est je ne suis plus du tout
là-dedans il dit ça au juge alors enfin
on sait ce qu'il a dit à la juge au
sujet de l'énorme médiatisation de son
affaire il a dénoncé le traitement
médiatique et s'est dit choqué par les
accusations de pédopordographie don qui
lui ont été porté pendant un moment
c'est dégueulasse il paraît que c'est la
ronçon de la gloire on m'accuse de
pédopornographie entre autres à
fabulation je ne réponds pas euh je ne
réponds pas pour pas que ça ne se
retourne contre moi un rappeur a proposé
la peine de mort avec la torture on me
dit de ne pas lire ça ne s'arrête pas on
ne fait pas le procès de l'accident mais
de toute ma vie vraie ou fausse euh donc
là c'est vrai qu'il a il a reparlé de de
tout ça hein oui ça je peux le
comprendre d'autant qu'il y a euh rien
en ce qui concerne le
volet
pelopornographique l'enquête a été menée
par les les policier et il ne ressort
rigoureusement rien donc il a été un peu
mis dans la dans la fusse au Lyon euh où
on a évoqué qu'il avait pu être addicte
lui aussi de de de de choses comme ça et
en fait il a été disculpé là-dessus
merci en tout cas merci Michel Marie
merci g merci à tous tout de suite c'est
géon sur C8
merci